the answer to your problems is to take
more action stop thinking about it stop
over planning stop telling people what
you're going to do and just start taking
action
[Music]
I don't know how you're going to get any
results through believing unless you put
some action back of that belief
the internet'll if you tell your mind
off enough that you have faith in
anything the time will come when your
subconscious mind will accept that even
if you tell your mind off your love that
you have faith in yourself life shrinks
and life expands in direct proportion to
your willingness to assume risk yeah I'm
like I've made some really stupid
decisions in my career for my entire
career on a broad plane they've all
worked out
every time I've quit my jobs I've done
every time I've had a job people that I
trust most to treat people that I love
all advise against it my dad told me not
to move to New York City because it was
such a risk and every time I every time
I took these bigger risks the
opportunity for a larger payout was
always there the essence is is when you
have nothing to lose you they're backed
into a corner or and you cower and you
submit or you fight your way out and so
I've been backed into a corner a few
times both when I was a kid but then
also in my professional career when I
decided to become an entrepreneur when
the recession hit you know I had to
apply that same mindset in 1998 when I
was working for another company
I was bumming an arwing of whether to
set up my own business I didn't have a
lot of money but I decided to take
action I decided to do it but I did it
in a very planned way I knew exactly
what I was going to do I knew exactly
what I wanted to achieve but the most
important thing I took action within two
or three years I was a millionaire again
I took five years of my life to build my
advertising career and I made like a lot
of money I've been doing really great
I ditched it all to pursue something I
mean nothing about this huge risk and I
did it at a time when my wife was
pregnant and there was all of this
vulnerability and all the scariness in
my life and that's what the struggle has
always been for me is like identifying
this identifying fear and then just
smashing through it
[Music]
yeah you know what fear is it's a trap
and people are domesticated so to speak
so you know they're comfortable and if
they just realize that they have nothing
to lose you know these middle-class
folks here you know they think they have
something to lose they think that their
reputation with their neighbors or their
credit or their Louie Vuitton luggage or
whatever it is don't let your fears
become boxes that enclose you open them
out feel them and turn them into the
greatest courage you're capable of I
promise you nothing will go wrong
but if you live by your fears everything
that can pass possibly go wrong will go
wrong you want to improve you want to
get better you want to get on a workout
program or a clean diet you want to
start a business you want to write a
book or make a movie or build a house or
a computer or put together some mobile
application
[Music]
where do you start
you start right here and when do you
start you start right now you initiate
the action aggressively you go every
great wizard in history started out
there's nothing more than what we are
now students if they can do it why not
us if you're a writer and that's what
you spend a huge amount of time doing
you do the ideas through come to you but
nothing had ever come so with such a I
had this I thought I'd love to write
back and when I got off the train I went
straight home and I started writing life
is like this super temporary mega
fragile thing you only get like a nugget
of time to really pursue the things you
care about and my rule is that the right
time is always right if you're sitting
here like no I'm on trip or not just in
the class you just seriously concentrate
on where we are at this exact moment in
the market and recognize how full it is
for you how much of advantage you have
you may want to seriously consider and
take advantage if it collapses tomorrow
if there's a bubble burst you even have
to wait three to five years to get this
shot the bubbles burst no kid with an
idea gets
got it
the day I taught Eagle Eradicator I was
two weeks into my teacher training and I
said f it let's go and I just went and I
felt so much pressure off I felt so much
lift because I just knew I felt this
technology must be shared I can't hold
it I can't keep it for myself I can't
just sit in my apartment by myself like
this I gotta give this every human-being
has a five second window might even be
shorter for you you have about a five
second window in which you can move from
idea to action before your brain kicks
into full gear and sabotages any change
in behavior because remember your brain
is wired to stop you from doing things
that are uncomfortable or uncertain or
scary it's your job to learn how to move
from those ideas that could change
everything into acting on
I spent so much time thinking in my mind
is this the right choice for me is this
the right career for me should I try and
build a business around them I said
that's such a dumb way to go around it
like you should just engage an
experience and actually get your foot in
the industry that can inform whether or
not you should move ahead stress
primarily comes from not taking action
over something that you can have some
control over I find as soon as I
identify it and make the first phone
call or send off the first email message
or whatever it is that we're gonna do to
start to address that situation even if
it's not solved the mere fact that we're
addressing it dramatically reduces any
stress that might come from so stress
comes from ignoring things that you
shouldn't be ignoring every failure in
my life whether it be personal financial
in any kind of way business whatever
it's because of a lack of my attempt to
take action I did not take action and if
you have delay taking action repeatedly
over and over again you develop the
habit of never taking action you get the
job the habit of procrastination holding
back and so on so many people will wait
or tell you they're gonna write this
novel or they're gonna do this they're
gonna make this film they never do it
[Music]
we want to change we want to live a
better life we want to create more for
our families we want to be happier the
the desire is there again it's about how
do you go from knowledge to action think
about this the last six letters of the
word attractions fell what AC tion
action here's the strategy for success
of the secret right go into your house
and go quiet room and you close the
lights draw the shades and sit on a
couch and visualize a big fat check
twenty-five G's thousand bucks us okay
with your name on it and I want you to
imagine that check and just make that
check go bigger in your mind and make it
real more real and just put it out into
the ether of the universe and the law of
attraction will take hold just think
about it both bright secret is a load of
crap okay until I believe in
manifestation yeah damn straight I do
but you got to take action I'm one of
those unfortunate people I tried it I
really thought I tried it but I read the
books all let me try you know so I said
I'd try to pray for the check never came
but I went out and started taking action
guess what the check came with a few a
couple of zeros
but some days I'd come home from school
sit down and go I'm just gonna wait for
the inspiration to him you know wait for
the idea to come fully formed and when I
got a joke then I'll go draw it and I
would sit there for maybe three or four
hours then go
alright screwed I had to get up in this
I got to do the process I got to sit
there and just start drawing I don't
even know why or how I'm gonna get there
and then two things would come together
and it'll be oh there's an idea this is
the first panel to say but and then it
would come together always it would not
take very long I would fight that
process so much because as long as I do
it I was waiting for inspiration before
I acted it's always the other way around
just start moving then the inspiration
will come
you got to check yourself before you
wreck yourself like stop complaining
stop talking yourself in your head and
do something
only thing that matters is your work and
so when I finally realized that and
started to make small things and try to
move them around festivals and just you
know just share my work you know the
energy behind that positive intention
started a ball rolling
power of an intention is great but
without any initiative it's dead right a
dream is great but without any movement
it's dead you have to be moving towards
everyday
write something every day you can create
something every day you can contribute
something but it has to be daily
otherwise it will never become
actualized keep every single day
momentum going and if you don't do that
there's no chance
and then we clear the path and we are
guided to the next right action and that
is the most magnificent thing we could
do right now and that means you gotta
stop thinking about it
and stop dreaming about it and stop
researching every aspect of it and
reading all about it and debating the
pros and cons of it just start doing it
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed the believe film series
is the series it takes the most time
probably right now on my channel it's a
new series we're still testing it I
would love love love love love to get
your feedback what do you think should
we continue can we make it better other
topics you want us to cover next please
let me know I want the series to
continue but your feedback will help
dictate that for us leave your thoughts
down in the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details